Welcome to The Explainer.
Today we're jumping into a
really gripping story of
rebellion and rescue set in the
grim, oppressive land of
Barovia.
And this isn't just a tale about
heroes, it's a minute by minute
breakdown of our desperate plan
can just completely unravel into
chaos.
So picture this.
In the town square of Valaki, 2
prisoners are standing on a
brand new gallows.
Their fate has just been sealed
by the town's new iron fisted
leader.
The burger mistress walked her.
She's yelling this out to a
crowd of just silent, miserable
peasants.
This whole thing is supposed to
be a show of force, you know, a
way to restore order.
But it's about to become a
battlefield.
To really understand the
violence that's about to
explode, we've got to rewind
just a few hours.
We're going back to a desperate
plan that was hatched in the
last safe place in town.
We're a new and, let's be
honest, very uneasy alliance was
being formed.
OK, let's get into it.
Our story really kicks off at
the Blue Water Inn.
A couple of adventures.
Radley and Traxidor have been
captured, and their friends
they're scrambling, trying to
figure out anyway literally any
way to get them back.
The whole rescue mission falls
to two pretty unlikely allies.
On one side you've got Damon.
He's a guy who just stumbled
into this nightmare land, and
he's become fiercely loyal to
the new friends he's made.
And on the other side, that's
your horn.
A seasoned mist Walker, he's one
of the few who can navigate the
cursed mist that trap everyone
else.
Here.
He's driven by his own mission
of revenge against the lands
vampiric ruler Strawd.
So yeah, totally different
paths.
But they have one immediate
goal.
Save their friends.
So their first move is to try
and get some Intel.
Yurihorn knows only one
potential ally in this whole
cursed land, the legendary
Monster Hunter Rudolf Van
Richten, who happens to be
hiding out in Valaki under a
magical disguise.
You'd think a guy with his
experience, he's got to know
where they keep prisoners,
right?
But Nope, it's a total dead end.
Van Richten is completely
focused on his own quest for
revenge.
He knows absolutely nothing
about how Valaki works and
offers zero help.
It's a huge disappointment and
it sends you to horn right back
to square 1.
And this is where they learn the
grim truth from the innkeeper
Danica.
There is no prison.
Valaki doesn't hold people for
long.
If you commit a serious crime,
you get a public spectacle,
ashamed trial followed
immediately by an execution.
So their friends aren't just
captured, they're on death row.
And the clock is kicking fast.
With the stakes that high and a
public execution on the horizon,
the heroes know they need every
single advantage they can get.
And that means Urihorn has to
break the town's super strict
curfew to go get their one
secret weapon.
So Yurihorn, he moves like a
ghost through the dark streets.
He waits for a lone guard to
pass, then scales the town wall
and lets out this low whistle.
A moment later, this massive
shadow just detaches itself from
the woods.
It's his Panther companion, and
it's silently climbs the
palisade to join him.
And in a detail that just
perfectly captures how grim this
place is, the Panther doesn't
show up empty handed.
Oh, no, it brings a gift.
A severed human forearm,
probably from a victim of a
recent vampire attack.
You're a horn actually has to
wrestle this macabre trophy away
from his growling companion
before they can sneak back to
the end.
All right, let's Fast forward to
noon the next day, right at the
gallows, and see how this
desperate plan just explodes
into unpredictable violence.
The heroes have scouted the area
and they are ready to spring
their trap.
So as noon hits, everyone is in
position.
Derriman's hiding in some ruins,
Yori Horn and his Panther are
perched up on a rooftop, and on
the gallows their friends are
completely helpless.
Traxidor looks like he's been
drugged, totally unresponsive,
and Radley is blinded by a
locked iron mask.
Facing them is the Burgamestress
with her whole crew.
The ambush kicks off with a
volley of arrows and the square
is instantly thrown into chaos.
But that initial advantage, it
just vanishes in seconds as the
whole situation escalates with
some shocking transformations
and a really brutal counter
attack.
Just as the fight starts, the
heroes get some completely
unexpected backup.
The innkeepers, Irwin and Danica
Martikoff suddenly morphed from
simple Ravens into these
humanoid bird creatures wear
Ravens, and they just throw
themselves into the fight,
attacking the guards on the
gallows.
They are clearly not what they
seemed, but the hero's main
target, the Burger mistress.
She is far from helpless.
She immediately throws up this
shimmering magical shield that
seems to deflect any attack
aimed at her.
Her wardens start unleashing
dark necromantic spells and
whenever her guards get hurt she
just heals them.
A quick victory is completely
impossible.
Now.
The rescuers are skilled for
sure, but they are just
outmatched and outnumbered.
Radley, still blinded, is trying
to head butt guards, but it's
not really working.
Derman gets struck down by a
powerful spell.
The relentless assault from the
guards and the wardens just
wears them down and in rapid
succession, both Radley and
Derman Hall unconscious.
The rescue is failing badly.
With two of their own down and
the battle completely lost, the
allies that are still standing
have to make a terrible choice,
save who they can or die right
there with them.
In a moment of just sheer
desperation, the were Ravens
abandoned the fight.
They grab the unconscious bodies
of Derman and Radley, throw them
on their shoulders, and despite
taking multiple spear wounds,
they fight their way to the
prisoner's cart.
Yuri Horn and his Panther leap
down to follow as the wagon just
tears out of the square, leaving
the guards in the dust.
But in the chaos of the retreat,
one person is forgotten.
Traxidor, still dazed and
drugged, is left standing on the
gallows all alone to face the
full, uninterrupted wrath of the
bergamot stress that is the
terrible cost of their survival.
The fleeing wagon eventually
stops at an abandoned house.
The unconscious heroes are
dragged into a rough cellar by
Danica, and because she's a Ware
Raven, her gruesome injuries are
already healing at this
unnatural rate.
Before she leaves, she gives
them one final Stark warning.
She tells them to stay put until
the coast is clear, and then she
seals them in, hiding the cellar
entrance under piles of junk
before turning back into a Raven
and flying away.
And that's where we leave them.
Hidden, wounded, and having paid
an unthinkable price for a
failed rescue.
They survived, sure, but now
they're fugitives in a town
controlled by the very people
they just attacked, and one of
their friends is still in enemy
hands.
The question is, what now?